Perrec c'est
moi c'est de lui que tu tiens ton nom
parce que c'était un héros c'était
quelqu'un de courageux brillant gentil
et pers a trouvé le moyen d'avoir une
fin
heureuse j'ai l'habitude de de pas me
sentir à ma place comme si j'étais un
puzzle avec de mauvaises pièces mais ces
derniers temps j'ai l'impression que
quelque chose a changé Percy tu n'es pas
comme les autres quand tu seras prêt à
entendre ce que les dieux gardent en
réserve pour toi ils te le diront perci
ces histoires que je t'ai raconté sur
les dieux grecs celles avec des héros et
des monstres
elles sont bien
réelles non arrête c'est n'importe quoi
tu es un sang mêlé et les sang mêlés ne
sont pas en sécurité dans ce monde j'ai
tout fait pour te préparer à ce qui
t'attend accrochez-vous
merc Jackson ton père a besoin de ton
aide on a dérobé la foudre de Ze il
exige que son éclair lu soit rendu où ce
sera la guerre
taqute et de le
retrouver je sais que ça peut paraître
angoissant mais tu ne seras pas seul on
est toujours TR pour entreprendre une
quête les demieux perçoivent la réalité
d'une autre manière alorsut trouve ce
pourquoi tu es
doué j'ai droit à un autre essai non
non il y a pas de place pour moi
ici tu n'as toujours pas trouvé ta
place l'oracle nous a confié une quête
pour aider les dieux tu croyais que ce
serait facile salut bienvenue les
demidieux maman je peux pas te laisser
perc Jackson sois sans crainte brave la
tempête
ça se trouve j'aurais pas besoin d'une
épée
ok je vais en avoir
besoin